Airwolf Knight Rider The Six Million
Dollar Man and the A-Team all to be
rebooted but all to exist in the same
universe and cross over with each other
constantly
welcome to side tracking Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so first of all I'm going to explain
this idea and then I'm going to tell you
where it's come from and how likely I
think it is that it's actually going to
happen
but apparently this has been pitched at
Universal for the peacock Network the
plan is to reboot the A-Team it would be
a hard reboot a new team obviously
they're not going to bring back those
actors
several of them are dead
they're going to reboot the Knight Rider
they're going to reboot the six billion
dollar man but we'll come back to that
in a second because that's going to be a
little bit separate to the rest of it
and they're going to reboot Airwolf now
I've told you that they're going to
reboot Airwolf already this idea has
been knocking around for months but it's
grown so the idea is that we'll have
these three TV shows it would actually
be a team Airwolf and Knight Rider that
as I say those three series will then
exist within the same universe they will
cross over with each other I.E the
overarching storyline and there will be
there'll be one big storyline that these
three series will run along will
actually influence each other and that
actually they'll have crossovers I.E
Knight Rider Pune 18 the 18 Imperial
Knight Rider they'll all appear in
Airwolf etc etc the idea being it would
be like what Marvel have done with the
comic books but Universal are going to
do it with these 1990s action kids shows
the six billion dollar man now the idea
with that is a little bit differently as
in the six billion dollar man would be
million dollar amount will exist within
this universe but he won't actually have
his own series the problem is that Mark
Wahlberg is still planning and still
trying to get off the ground a movie of
the six billion dollar man and it was
brought up basically during the pitch
meetings that um they didn't want to
push forward with a series of the six
billion dollar man because they were
worried it was basically step on the
toes of the moving confused audiences
blah blah blah so apparently Executives
in the pitch meeting said why don't you
just have the character bouncing between
the three and the small executive team
that had come up with this idea of this
reboot agreed and that is now the plan
that they are discussing between
themselves at Universal and NBC so I am
actually told that this is an idea that
has come from a small group of
Executives at NBC Studios these are
quite lower Executives that have come up
with this idea themselves apparently
this team works on sort of future
development idea is so how do I think
this will work
I really don't know
um the the source that's told me about
this and I think they're bang on has
basically said that in their sort of
team because he doesn't actually work
for NBC he works for a quite a large um
talent agency and they were talking
about this idea because it's basically
come to them sort of saying like well
what sort of do you think any directors
any writers or something would be
interested in this
so they sort of like talking about it
and he said their ideas this is either
absolutely genius or completely moronic
and they really can't quite decide which
way to go with it Picard season three I
think is really the big thing that has
made Studios realize that actually if
you do a Revival and Nostalgia does very
well with the audiences if it's done
properly
I think even revivals of things like
Criminal Minds are shown that actually
if it's done well and done right people
are very very keen on it
but things like the 18 movie reboot
didn't do as well as hoped and attempts
to revive Knight Rider have gone very
badly a few times
so it has to be done carefully so the
executive seemed to have come at this
with the idea of well let's go big or
let's go home
and by going big they mean let's create
an entire franchise franchise is a big
word in studios at the moment actually
HBO and almost all of the top Executives
at all of the big streaming services
that's all they talk about franchises
the idea being though that actually they
could have massive crossover events
straight to Peacock TV movies
potentially etc etc and they could
really build something big around iconic
characters I actually think if they do
this right
it could be genius and I mean properly
genius an audience of people my age 40
somethings
we'll watch this they would watch a
bionic man movie TV movie potentially
they will watch The Bionic Man in an
episode of The A-Team they will watch
Airwolf flying overnight Rider basically
isn't it kind of all of our dreams
rolled into one I think it might be a
little bit for me I actually I'm quite
excited by this idea if they do it
properly but do I actually think it will
happen
well you'll know from a couple of days
ago I did a video about Blue Thunder
reboot and I'm afraid this is going to
come under a similar category as this
idea at the moment Executives in studios
are sitting around with very little to
do they have kind of gone through all of
their existing projects and a lot have
already been canceled but now Studio
bosses are saying what are we going to
do new
when we come back from these strikes we
have to announce something to excite
people the Studio's reputation
is not great right now so let's announce
something really exciting to get people
really interested again and hopefully
maybe they'll forget how badly we've
treated the actors and the writers in
the last six months there's an element
of that but there's also an element of
they've just got nothing better to do so
they're sat round thinking of ideas and
pitching those ideas now the Blue
Thunder and this whole
1980s Nostalgia Revival Knight Rider 18
Bionic Man and Airwolf plan might
basically be just that because I'm also
told that in another Studio some idiot
actually pitched a snakes on the plane
series for Netflix now thanks to the
plane I thought Samuel Jackson was
actually a brilliant film but that film
basically got made because the chief of
that studio basically went what's the
stupidest title we've got in the you
know that we own right now somebody went
we've got this film called Snakes on a
Plane and he went sold and that's how he
got made it got made because it sounded
stupid a streaming series based on it
for Netflix
that's a stupid idea for me
but those are the sort of ideas that are
being bounced around at the moment so
let's see if any of the ideas come to
fruition because actually even though I
don't want to see a snakes on the plane
streaming series
I do want to see The A Team I do want to
see Knight Rider and I kind of want to
see Airwolf get revived and if we get a
reboot of those and they actually then
exist in the same universe and they
cross over with each other done well
I actually think that's quite exciting
but what do you think get to the
comments and tell me are these three
series that you would love to see
existing within the same universe are
these characters and stories that we
want back is the bionic man then maybe
appearing across these a good idea as
well considering that there is
potentially a Mark Wahlberg movie coming
or actually do you want to see that
series as well so four series on peacock
all crossing over with each other get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you'd love to see
but basically and tell me is this a good
idea or is this moronic
please get to the comments also check
the Community page when this video goes
live I will be putting a poll up so tell
me what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and you get to see
them without any of the adverts for a
small contribution each month that
really supports the channel
you can also go to scitrac.co.uk where
we do articles based on most of our
videos and we try to add a little bit
more opinion and information in there
for you to digest
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]